yall already know what it is it's bad
notes [ __ ] and this week we get a
serious about the bread with the
Merchant of Venice by William
Shakespeare
noble brother beside y'all got it bad
for a girl got as much paper and she got
that booty mmm
Portia Belmont do you want to put a ring
on it but he blowing all this chatter
and now he ain't got the ends to get an
uptown girl like her the holla back
so Bassanio hit up his boy Antonio a her
rich merchant from the block and be like
say brah
Thank You confront me some cash money so
I can get my wall with this banging
honey
you know I'll hit you back man and Tonio
like no dice brah I'm cashed out cuz all
my bread invested in sand ships that are
flowing in the sea but look I'll cover
your ass if you can find a lender up in
Belmont Porsche you're straight buggin
cuz their daddies will say she got a
Mary whichever dude picks the right
chest out of three one gold one silver
and one lid man what counters is that
Porsha ain't feeling nothing I'm gonna
be lookin mofos trying to hit it but
then her main homegirl Nerissa say maybe
that legit Playa Bassanio will drop by
he's so full back in V town Bassanio hit
up a Jewish moneylender named [ __ ]
and tell'em Antonio gonna guarantee a
loan of three g's thing is [ __ ] got
beef with Antonio cuz shy guy don't like
the way Antonio do business and always
be hating on his Jewish roots so he
agreed to lend on the cash under one
condition
if Bassanio can't pay up in three months
[ __ ] gonna take a pound of Antonio's
flesh man that's steep brah and tell me
oh say I don't suppose on you'll get
that cash money and peace out the
Belmont with this boy Graziano my
[ __ ] busy plotting his daughter
Jessica run off and marry Antonio's
homey Lorenzo damn it bill my Porsche
drowning and a bunch of lame-ass
Buster's all jonesing to get a crack at
badass but first they gotta choose from
them three chests the first two scrubs
picked the gold and silver but daddy
ain't gonna unlock them legs player then
Bassanio drop into town roll up to the
scene and pick the lad chest like a boss
that's right boy Portia all yours man
support should give them a ring and say
you best not ever take this thing off
damn girl
my Graziano say he an erisa and love to
so they suggest a double wedding cuz go
big or go home
right just as they bout to pop bottles
they get word that Antonio's ships are
lost at sea so he ain't got the money to
pay [ __ ] back when Bassanio hear this
he likes I got a bus ass home and save
my boy Porcha give her booze some fat
stacks to pay off the debt but she got
another plan she cooking up she and the
wrists are gonna dress up as dudes and
slang over the Venice I bet court
Bassanio offers [ __ ] six big ones
twice the original loan but [ __ ] like
naw blood
I want that pound of flesh the Duke of
Venice looking for some advice on the
case
so why comes illegally his name
Balthazar but on the real it's Portia
dressed up like a dude she's still fine
though girls started talking about how I
like need to show mercy
so Antonio ready to get carved up real
good but the important like hold up yeah
the law say you can have a pound of its
flesh but it don't say you can draw any
of his blood blood spill a single drop
and your crib and all your money belongs
to the law so good luck with that
[ __ ] like fine I'll just take the
cash but Portia say uh-uh not so fast
Playboy
since you tried the ice Venetian citizen
you got to give up all your property 5 -
the state has tell Antonio and then the
Duke get to decide whether you live or
die they do pity the fool and let them
walk away and tell you say I son
I'll give you your cash back on two
conditions one you got to become a
Christian and two you leave all your
Benjamins to Lorenzo and Jessica after
you die [ __ ] like hi fine pieces out
not knowing Balthazar is really his
woman but sorry you'll try to throw her
some mad gratitude but Portia like yo
Playboy I want that ring and Nerissa
disguises Balthazar's right-hand man say
the same thing
Graziano both boys hand over the bling
and head back to the crib with Portia
and Nerissa be chillin yo where the hell
are your rings
but before she'd go too far the girls
revealed that dumb boys just got Punk'd
and it's all good in the end Lorenzo
will all get to know that I have to
shout like bite the dust he and Jessica
gonna be buried in Benjamins and it's
howdy he'll get worried that his ships
all good
so it's paper still legit my man Willy
shakes is so gangsta that when he bust a
mad lyrical flow it changed the way
people talk for all time you ever heard
of somebody saying that they gonna take
a pound of flesh and then get paid yep
it came from this play right here I have
you ever heard of someone who's shady
with money called a shyster yeah man
that came from our boy [ __ ] and well
that's where it stuff starts getting
messy see this plate is one of the most
notorious of all the bad blonds works
what's the beef well open up your ears
and soak this game up most scholars say
that the main jam of this Texas their
holy rollin with Jesus make your thuggin
all righteous but if you ain't like say
you Jewish
then your balls are way out of whack now
keep in mind this mess was written back
in the day when this kind of prejudice
against foreigners was going down on the
Red Sea Antonio rapping all the virtuous
things Christianity preaching like so a
mad love to your neighbor
Antonio's wallet always open to his
homies
he never charges any points on top of
the principal and dude offers up his own
life just to get his boys back where a
shot like supposed to wrap all the
crooked morals you might have when you
sippin on that latter cheves instead of
that Jesus juice for one shall I only
got one thing on his mind I'm stacking
paper off other people's problems and
with homies asked him to show a little
mercy up at court he would rather see
Antonio flee doubt and die like a [ __ ]
so was the bard really throwing shade at
Jule's I was he playing a most subtle
game if you look close it ain't just
[ __ ] who acted Shady everybody got
that side whether they christened
oh whatever for example the Shakespeare
really saying Christians are more legit
towards their fellow man
then wise Antonia always talking about
[ __ ] and calling him a dog cuz on the
real crowd like ain't the only one on
that vengence grind and Tonio show is
hell don't turn the other cheek when he
makes [ __ ] Humbert
and tell him how he supposed to spend
his money no matter what they do you
representing you might want to dole out
a little payback
like [ __ ] say if a Jew wrong a
Christian what is his humility revenge
if a Christian wrong a Jew what should
his sufferance be by Christian example
why revenge how about that boy Bassanio
everybody always running their mouths
about [ __ ] being obsessed with the
friend but why do beside you got it
there for Portia cuz she rich man as he
say and Belmont is a lady richly left
Portia ain't no saint either girl don't
want to marry the Prince of Morocco just
cause of the color of his skin he's a
prince if I could bid the fifth welcome
with so good hard as I can bid the other
four farewell I should be glad of his
approach if he had the condition of a
saint and the complexion of a devil I
had rather he should drive me then widen
me that's some bullsh
but it don't stop there yeah Antonio's a
pretty generous brother willing to
sacrifice himself for his homie it's
[ __ ] but he never shut the hell up about
it it's like he trying to get people to
talk about him like he's freaking Jesus
I am a tainted weather of the flock meat
is for death the weakest kind of fruit
drops earliest to the ground and so let
me you can not better be employed
Bassanio than to live still and write my
epitaph is he really as selfless as he
say I do he just have a big-ass head so
look there ain't no doubt this play got
the stank of more prejudiced times all
up on it but what's all Willie really
saying that religion to find the way you
treat another brother I did he pull a
fast one by suddenly calling out them
Elizabethans on their book either way
your boy Sparky no there anyone to have
a serious hater Street to him no matter
what religion they represent yo thanks
for chilling
boy keep it real up in the library yard
hey y'all thanks for watch what a
checkout a Shakespearean spin on a
modern tale go to audible.com slash low
notes and download William Shakespeare's
Star Wars by Ian desh
it's the classic tale from a galaxy far
far away we tell it as a Shakespearean
play it's pretty dope audiobooks are a
great way to make time fly whether you
want a soul-crushing commute a pumpkin
iron at the gym audible makes it easy to
enjoy an automat selection of audiobooks
original audio shows comedy and more no
matter where you are just go to
audible.com slash snuggums to start a
free 30-day trial when you sign up you
can pick William Shakespeare's Star Wars
the thug notes book or any book you want
download it for free and it's yours to
keep forever but more about all the
bullying to start your 30-day free trial
with a free audio book go to audible.com
slash Thutmose to sign up thanks to
audible for sponsoring this video we've
got lots of great stuff coming so don't
miss out click here to go to our channel
page and subscribe catch you next time I
well-read Ballas
peace